je suis révolté je pense que nos
démocraties républicaines sont vraiment
en danger
ç'a failli embraser l'immeuble d'autres
voitures c'est des gens n'avaient pas
réagi
on a passé une très mauvaise soirée
accueil mon épouse hier soir une
mauvaise nuit
et puis on pense à tous nos voisins
aussi on expose tout le monde mais c'est
c'est un épisode gravissime
après tout une séquence de un an où j'ai
subi des insultes
les violences verbales des faux compte
twitter des rumeurs d intimidation c'est
extrêmement difficile par moments voilà
donc je pense qu'il va falloir que tout
le monde tous ensemble réagissent c'est
à dire stop ça suffit de s'en prendre en
permanence à ceux qui ont une
responsabilité ou une autre des élites
ce qu'on appelle les élites en général
soit disant la france d'en haut par
rapport à la france d'en bas soit des
élites politiques ou autres y compris le
gouvernement tape et matin midi et soir
sur sur le gouvernement qu on peut
critiquer on peut avoir des débats
démocratiques mais faut arrêter de tout
noircir en permanence et on ne fait que
repousser les limites de la violence et
quand il n'ya plus d'emilia plus de
bornes ya la pluie quand on dépasse les
bornes n'y a plus de limites
mais il y en aura d'autres
malheureusement si on n'arrête pas de
ses invectives permanente moyens aux
premières loges mais je vois bien
globalement la société dont dans son
ensemble et à travers les réseaux
sociaux en particulier des insultes des
menaces les intimidations y compris par
des élus de la république
ici à besançon voilà c'est totalement
insupportable c'est inadmissible
vous avez souvenirs d'attac de bien
comme ça appartenant à des élus de la
république
mais vous savez lors d'une manifestation
grande rue devant ma permanence de
campagne
un soir et des torches ont été déposées
et les vitrines était tout noir tu pas
qu'il ya eu un incendie mais on aurait
pu ne serait-ce que ce jour là à voir un
incendie alors il ya eu effectivement il
ya quelques mois certain nombre de mes
collègues députés qui ont et ont fait
l'objet d'attaqués d'intimidation voire
pénétration dans des permanences de
tentatives d'incendié
aussi alors c'est pas les mêmes plats
ont visiblement sur un groupe anarchiste
enquête judiciaire est en cours le
procureur
si la police judiciaire confère une
enquête donc on n'est pas dans le même
cadre que ce qu'ont subi mes collègues
c'était plutôt des c'est pas trop des
des manifestants d'une manière générale
quelle que soit leur appartenance à des
associations des syndicats des partis
classiques et voilà donc c'était
vraiment malade il va falloir trouver un
peu plus de bienveillance et de
compréhension de comment c'est difficile
dans notre société on a can crise a
raison oui c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui souffrent c'est vrai et ce
qui la plupart des gens qui sont au
pouvoir sont sincères et c'est de
trouver des solutions
ils n'ont pas toujours les moyens pour
point fr et ça vient de loin et c'est
pas qu'en france c'est partout dans le
monde et c'est pour ça qu'on va aussi
c'est ces mouvements populistes et je ne
suis pas péjoratif quand je dis ça mais
avec des gouvernements aussi populiste
qui font pas mieux d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils sont confrontés aux mêmes au même
problème donc retroussons nous les
manches pour un ensemble essayer de
régler les problèmes et d'apporter des
solutions à chacun mais pas par ce moyen
là pas par la violence par parleurs le
procès d'intention permanent par la
critique permanente c'est trop ensemble
des solutions
on a senti votre épouse
sur le coeur est ce que ça peut remettre
votre engagement politique en cause ça
fait longtemps que je fais de la
politique je ne savais c'est comme la
grenouille qu'on met dans l'eau chaude
c'est la température est montée
progressivement donc je m'en suis pas
forcément aperçu je n'étais pas projeté
d'un seul coup dans cette ambiance là ça
fait trente ans que je vois le
l'escaladent dont je me suis adapté à
cette situation et je fais font parce
que mon mon engagement aussi c'est je
dois résister à ça ce mouvement là il me
battre et ils mener cette bataille
politique contre la violence contre les
fausses informations contre les
manoeuvres de toutes sortes et de ce
point de vue là je reste déterminé mais
c'est vrai que si ça doit mettre en
cause pas seulement ma sécurité mais mon
bien-être familial et autres la question
pourrait se poser un peu plus jamais
l'exclure c'est pas mon état d'esprit
aujourd'hui
mais a passé une très mauvaise soirée
2000 fait plus en plus difficile d'être
élu oui vous savez je alors chacun vit
une situation différente ça dépend c'est
souvent plus confortable pour les gens
qui sont dans l'opposition parce que
voilà ils seront ceux qui peuvent se
permettre de critiquer quand on est
associés à la gouvernance au pouvoir
d'une manière ou d'une autre
oui c'est plus en plus difficile j'ai vu
les j'ai vu deux
l'évolution et moi j'assume d'être au
pouvoir d'avoir les mains dans le
conduit de dire que c'est difficile de
dire que je suis frustré aussi comprend
pas toujours les bonnes décisions et
capable toujours une bonne décision il
soit le premier ministre lui dire son
aile crise sanitaire j'ai le choix entre
des mauvaises décisions
il ya des fois des moments comme ça où
c'est extrêmement c'est extrêmement
difficile de prendre les bonnes
décisions trouver la bonne solution
trouver le chemin tout est complexe
voyez bien crise sociale crise
économique crise crise écologique crise
morale crise démocratique
tout ça en même temps je reviens c'est
un d'esprit est votre situation
personnelle ou dénoncer une escalade au
cours des derniers mois est ce que
aujourd'hui vous irait jusqu'à dire que
être élu c'est aussi
savoir que potentiellement sa vie peut
être menacé vous sentez en danger
d'un naturel optimiste malgré tout j'ai
un regard du site sur la société la
clean au pessimisme
mais l'action l'action me équilibre ce
pessimiste parce que quand on est dans
l'action on se dit qu'on peut changer
changer les choses dont je reste
toujours eu confiance malgré tout et
puis j'ai envie de me battre
voilà m me battre contre c'est vrai que
j'ai fait l'objet depuis un an je suis
l'homme à battre de toutes parts de
toutes parts voilà donc je suis de plus
en plus cette escalade mais parfois me
galvanise et au contraire il faut pas
laisser filer cette société laisser
dériver cette société et avec l'âge que
j'ai l'expérience que j'ai je me sens
aussi cette responsabilité-là ne pas
baisser les bras et de tenir face à
cette dégradation de la relation sociale
et cette facilité à l'invectivé et à la
violence lors j'ai ça aussi qui me tient
ça je me dis tu peux pas abandonner
voilà tu veux pas laisser tomber il faut
que les gens qui tiennent debout qui ont
l'expérience et aussi soit là pour faire
face à cette terrible